we have three inequalities here that
involve absolute values and then below
them we have potential values for X and
what I want to do in this video is see
which of these potential values for X
actually make the inequality true so
let's start with this first one in green
here on the left it says the absolute
value of x is less than the absolute
value of negative seven so let's think
about which of these X values would make
this true and before I even try out the
x value so let's see if we can simplify
this inequality and the thing that might
jump out at you and I encourage you to
try these on your own before I work
through them what might jump out at you
is we know what the absolute value of
negative seven is the absolute value of
negative seven is how far from zero is
negative seven
well it's seven to the left it's the
distance from negative 7 to 0 is 7 or
another way to think about it is the if
you the absolute value of any number is
always going to be the non-negative
version of it so this right over here
absolute value of negative 7 is just
going to be 7 so an equivalent
inequality would be that the absolute
value of X needs to be less than 7 so
let's see if it's true for x equals
negative 8 so if x equals negative 8
then wherever we see the X we put in a
negative 8 there so let's see is it an
absolute value of negative 8 less than 7
is that true well the absolute value of
negative 8 is just going to be 8 so is 8
less than 7 no 8 greater than 7 so that
x equals negative 8 does not satisfy the
inequality now x equals negative 2 well
wherever we see the X let's put a
negative 2 so the absolute value of
negative 2 needs to be less than 7
what's the absolute value of negative 2
well it's going to be positive 2 is
positive 2 less than 7 sure 2 is less
than 7 so this this is x equals negative
2 satisfies our inequality the absolute
value of negative 2 is going to be less
than the absolute value of negative 7
then finally x equals 6 so the absolute
value is the absolute value of 6 once
again everywhere where I see the X I
just put these 6 there
x equals six we're going to say the
absolute value of six is that less than
seven well the absolute value of six is
once again just six six is six to the
right of zero is 6 less than seven yeah
sure
6 is less than 7 so x equals 6 and x
equals negative 2 both satisfy the
inequality now let's do this one here in
this magenta color and once again
encourage you to pause the video and try
to work through it out on your own so
let's try x equals negative 4 so if x
equals negative 4 we're going to say the
absolute value of negative 4 greater
than 5 absolute value of negative 4 well
that's just going to be 4 is 4 greater
than 5 no 4 is less than 5 so that
doesn't work now x equals 3
wherever where we see the X replace that
with a 3 the absolute value of 3 is that
greater than 5 absolute value of 3 is
just 3 so it's 3 greater than 5 no 3 is
less than 5 I think you see hopefully
you're getting the hang of it so finally
if x equals negative 9 the absolute
value of negative 9 that knee would need
to be greater than 5 absolute value of
negative 9 well that's just going to be
positive 9 so it's just going to be 9
and is that greater than 5 well sure 9
is greater than 5 so x equals negative 9
satisfies the inequality all right now
let's do these ones in this I guess this
light purple color the absolute value of
x needs to be greater than negative 16
so there's something very interesting
about this one we don't even have to
look at the choices here can you think
of any X for which this would not be
true well just think about a little bit
the absolute value of a number is it
ever going to be negative no the
absolute value of a number is going to
be 0 or positive it's going to be
non-negative so this right over here is
0 or positive or we could call that
non-negative 0 or positive so this thing
over here is 0 or positive something
that is 0 or greater something that is
or positive is always going to be
greater than a negative number so this
is actually true for all X's we don't
even have to try them out we can try
them out well actually we will try them
out just till you see that this is going
to be true for all X's because when you
take the absolute value if you take the
out if X is zero it's going to be zero
but for any other value any nonzero
value of X the absolute value of it is
going to be positive and let's just just
see that we could put any X there and
this statement is going to be true
absolute value of x equals negative
fifteen well the absolute value of
negative fifteen is that greater than
negative sixteen well the absolute value
of negative 15 is positive 15 and of
course positive 15 is going to be
greater than negative 16 a positive is
always going to be greater than a
negative so this is true if x equals
three absolute value of three is that
greater than negative 16 a whoops let me
write it that way absolute value of
three is that greater than negative 16
sure absolute value of 3 is 3 and 3 is
positive so it's going to be greater
than a negative number so that works and
as I said any X would work there and
then finally if x equals 9
well absolute value of 9 if x equals 9
is that greater than negative 16 well
sure that's just 9 and that is greater
than negative 16 even if X was 0 then
you would have 0 greater than negative
16 which is absolutely true so any X
here works